[موسيقى]
مرحبا كعادتنا في اخر موسم الرمضان يجب ان
نبدا في الطرح الاسئله على الجمهور
والنقاد ايضا طبعا سؤالنا الاول اليوم
وبعد ما شاهدنا كافه الاعمال الرمضانيه هل
تفوقت دراما هذا العام على دراما العام
الماضي وماذا كانت ابرز عناصر نجاح
الدراما هذا العام الشيف ان المسلسلات
رمضان السنه دي هي مسلسلات متنوعه بس مش
كلها متميزه يعني مش كلها حاجات مميزه
ومفتقدين في مسلسلات رمضان السنه دي العمل
الناس كلها بتشاور عليه وتقول العمل ده
كلنا بنحبه او احنا العمل ده اتبسطنا به
يعني في حاجات ممكن تعجب اذواق مختلفه بس
السنه اللي فاتت كان عندنا جزيره غمام كان
كان حاله جديده والناس كلها حباه في اكتر
من مسلسل بيناقش حوالي 3 مسلسلات بيناقشوا
حقبه تاريخيه غير اللي احنا عايشين فيها
فهو موسم متنوع ولكن زي ما قلت لك كده
مفتقد العمل اللي الناس كلها حتى في
الكوميدي كمان مفتاح العمل الناس كلها
تتفق عليه
اظهر اهتمام اقل بالمشاهده على التلفزيون
في مقابل اهتمام اكبر بالمتابعه على
المنصات ولذلك كان لابد ان نسالهم لماذا
على المنصات للامانه المنصات افضل ما في
دعايات او دعايات محدوده خلينا نحكي
بتشاهدها بالوقت اللي بدك اياه مش مقيد
بوقت معين فكانت المنصات افضل انا بصراحه
بتابعها على المنصات على التليفون عشان
الاعلانات ما بحبش الاعلانات هو طبعا
المنصات
ما فيش خلاف عليها لان الاعلانات بتاخد
مساحه كبيره جدا من الوقت بتخليك يعني انت
عقبال ما بتعرفش تركز مع حاجه كان زمان
على التليفزيون بس دلوقتي بسبب ان اعلانات
بقت كتيره بالزياده بقت اكثر من مسلسل
منصات احسن يعني دلوقتي بصراحه ربنا
التلفزيون مقرف قوي في اعلانات وبتابع
المنصات طبعا الاعلانات كثيره طبعا فعلا
بتاخد وقت من المسلسل وتخلي فعلا الواحد
يوتيوب طبعا والان مع فنانهم وفنانتهم
المفضلين هذا العام ولماذا المفضل احمد
ناصر القصبي ما يحتاج محمد رمضان اللي هو
جعفر العمده باسم ياخور في مسلسل العربي
ناصر القصبي صراحه وفي ناس كثيره احمد
فهمي سر البادئ وطبعا محمد رمضان عشان انا
شايفه عامل مسلسل كويس نصر القصبيه هو
اكثر فنان يعني لفت انتباهى المفضل عمرو
سعد
عمرو رمضان منصور امينه خليل في مسلسل
الهرشه السابعه فوز الشطي
نعم في حياتي المثاليه هي الصراحه ابدعت
في هذا الدور ونزكي بصراحه روبي عجباني في
حضره العمده كلهم انا شايفه عامر دول بردو
كويسين غاده عبد الرازق عامله مسلسل اسمه
مسلسل تلاته
يسد البيبان المفتوحه يبقى ابن اصول
الطريق دم بدم
يا
[موسيقى]
متابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات